[Music]  English lessons hello everybody  today's mini English lesson will be on  idioms  here are three gems you can use tomorrow  sound more like a native speaker  so you can say learning English at a  British Council is a piece of cake so  what do you mean by that  you mean it's easy alright it's  something nice it's something fun it's  easy if you're number two so I'm in the  pickle what do you mean by that you mean  that you are in a difficult situation  you have a problem okay  idiom number three to be the apple of my  eye  what do you mean by that it means that  you care about someone very deeply you  like that person very much  so to suit up remember piece of cake  okay number two to be in a pickle and  number three to be the apple of my eye  like you are guys I hope this has helped  you sound more like a native speaker and  then you can start using those idioms  like immediately okay so see you next  time bye bye  [Music]